Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new star wars mandalorian video and
breakdown of the new ahsoka tano teaser trailer
they've released this weekend when they explain
what's going on with her spin-off series so also
talk about what's happening with anakin skywalker
now because hayden christensen is coming back
because there have been so many questions about
the other projects he might show up in if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos obviously we have the mandalorian
season 2 finale coming up this week but i'll
be doing mandalorian season 3 videos really soon
and there's a couple other star wars series that
we'll be seeing during 2021. careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened on the mandalorian
so far if you haven't seen any of the episodes
yet starting with number 10. this past week you
probably saw they announced 10 total new star
wars series that they're releasing in the next
few years so that means eventually we're going
to be getting three to four new star wars series
every year but that probably won't be till
about 2022 before they ramp up to that volume
only two of those series though are going to
be direct spin-offs of the mandalorian and will
happen during the same time period where we are
right now after the end of season two the ahsoka
tano series with rosario dawson and then the
rangers of the new republic series about the
x-wing pilots patrolling the outer rim like carson
teva that we've seen the last couple of episodes
trapper wolfe dave felody's character the other
x-wing pilots i'll talk more about that at the
end of the video because this is more about ahsoka
tano and what she's going to be doing during her
series and what's going on with hayden christensen
coming back to star wars is anakin skywalker and
darth vader because some of the scenes he's
going to be filming for the obi-wan kenobi
series we learned will be flashbacks so a lot of
you have now asked if he's going to also appear
with ahsoka tano in some way there's a much
larger design behind all these plans you may
have also heard during the disney investor panel
that the mandalorian spin-offs will all culminate
in a big event crossover involving grand admiral
thrawn and probably moff gideon so i'll explain
how that's going to work during the video too
so they're going to have their own version of
avengers infinity war and avengers end game sort
of like the avengers series set in a mandalorian
cinematic universe in this part of the timeline if
you didn't see it they had a really short teaser
that they showed up with some concept footage the
really big easter egg with her logo here as a lot
of you have spotted is that this circle that's
actually rotating around and shifting is actually
a jedi meditation circle they show up during jedi
fallen order in the game they use those for game
saves but a lot of the symbols in the writing
around the edges here is just the ancient jedi
language you actually see it in the ancient jedi
texts during the star wars movies the reason why
it also kind of looks like a star chart for the
galaxy itself is because it's actually designed
to look like the world between worlds is sort of
this extra dimensional space within the force that
connects all times and places you can use it to
time travel to anywhere in the galaxy that you
want and ezra bridger used it to save ahsoka's
life and pluck her into a different time period
but number nine we finally got live action
ahsoka tano during the mandalorian season 2
episode 5 rosario dawson was fantastic as the
character especially given everyone who's been
watching ahsoka for the past 10 to 12 years
only knows her as ashley eckstein's version
of the character yes it's totally possible that
we could see ashley eckstein cameo as some other
character or be involved in some way during the
star wars ahsoka series it makes sense if she came
out as a character it would be during that series
both dave filoni and john favreau show runners of
the mandalorian are also executive producing the
ahsoka series and that other new republic series
after the episode dave filoni also came out and
clarified ahsoka's timeline between star wars
rebels the new series and what's going to be
happening with her spin-off series so number
eight they pretty much given away what the story
of her series is going to be between the ahsoka
ending scene from episode 5 of the mandalorian
the disney investor panel the past few weeks the
stuff that rosario dawson's been talking about all
the other star wars characters about the future of
ahsoka in the star wars universe when you sort
of pull from all these other sources you have a
pretty good idea of what's going to be happening
at the end of episode 5 she defeats morgan
ellsbeth who herself is from dathomir actually
so she's probably one of the night sisters so
hopefully we'll see some night sisters popping
up in the live-action shows soon we learned she
was one of grand admiral thrawn's lackeys and
ahsoka defeats her demanding that she tell her
where he is implying that she's still trying
to track thrawn down after the end of star wars
rebels so in a very broad sense the ahsoka series
will basically be the story of ahsoka vs thrawn
is way bigger than that involving a bunch of
mandalorian crossover and crossover with the other
spin-off series the rangers the new republic but
dave veloni said something really interesting a
few weeks ago that clarified the timeline and how
this is all going to work so the last time that we
saw ahsoka before she showed up on the mandalorian
live-action as rosario dawson previously everyone
had assumed that this last scene of ahsoka tano
and sabine wren during the star wars rebel finale
end credit scene was happening right before she
shows up on the mandalorian series there's a big
time jump that happens during that final episode
they have their final battle with grand admiral
thrawn ezra bridger sacrifices himself using
the space whale's ability to navigate hyperspace
naturally using the force he takes thrawn the
chimera his whole fleet of star destroyers
deep into the unknown regions where they can't
hurt the rebels and that was about a year or two
before the events of a new hope then there's a
big time jump and they show the celebrations of
all the different worlds they're having after
the second death star is destroyed in return
of the jedi they kinda did the same thing on the
mandalorian season two episode one with everybody
in the bar on tatooine getting wasted watching the
second death star blow up on the hollow net then
we see a much older version of sabine wren meeting
a much older version of ahsoka tano talking about
going to find ezra bridger because five plus years
later he still hasn't returned from wherever the
space whales took them so dave filoni came out
right after the ahsoka tano mandalorian episode to
clarify that this scene of them taking off to look
for ezra might actually happen after the events of
the mandalorian season 2 episode 5. at the time
the explanation seemed like it was unnecessarily
complicated but number six the reason why
i think dave filoni said that is because
he was unofficially confirming that their mission
ahsoka and sabine's mission to find ezra will be
covered during the ahsoka series they didn't
say how many seasons it would run but ahsoka
tano is such a huge character and there's so much
story for them to do it could go for at least five
to seven seasons if they wanted i'm sure rosario
dawson would be down for that too the whole thing
with live-action ezra bridger is that if grand
admiral thrawn is confirmed to have returned
from the unknown regions that's why ahsoka is
looking for him right now it also kind of confirms
that ezra bridger made it back too and it's up to
ahsoka and sabine and whoever else they bring back
from rebels like maybe rex will come back because
we have tamura morrison coming on as boba fett he
could also come back as the other clones rex is
still alive and present day it'll be up to them
to find out why ezra hasn't tried to make contact
with them since coming back and the reason for
that will probably wind up having something to do
with grand admiral thrawn's grand plans to conquer
the galaxy and all the stuff happening with moff
gideon because right now those two characters are
kind of like the new versions of darth vader in
the emperor palpatine of this new era of disney
plus series moff gideon being the darth vader
of this equation and thrawn being more like the
calculating more secretive emperor figure pulling
the strings from afar i've talked about this in
a couple of my other mandalorian videos but it
feels like there have been so many easter eggs
this season for the thrawn trilogy of books that
the new live-action thrawn story might be dave
filoni and jon favreau's version of a thrawn
trilogy for those of you that read the books
really awesome story that's technically still
legends dave filoni is the one that recanonized
thrawn through star wars rebels but he didn't
re-canonize everything from those stories so
i'm not expecting them to do a copy paste version
of a thrawn trilogy but imagine a version of that
thrawn trilogy just done across all the new series
that now connect with the mandalorian here's where
we get to the hayden christensen anakin skywalker
of it all though it was confirmed that he's coming
back to play darth vader and anakin on the obi-wan
kenobi series that series is set 10 years after
revenge of the sith which puts it about 15 years
before the events of the mandalorian in the ahsoka
series because the ahsoka series takes place
at the same time as the mandalorian series
darth vader normally walks around in his armor and
sounds like james earl jones with that deep voice
i am the father so the real reason is a lot of
you have probably guessed for casting hayden
christensen going through the trouble that or one
to do burnt scarred anakin with his mask off like
we see during rogue one in his regeneration
chamber in the baka tanks two to show him
speaking as anakin skywalker under his mask when
obi-wan probably winds up breaking it open with
his lightsaber so you're seeing anakin under the
mask and he sounds like anakin again and three it
was also reported that there's going to be some
sort of anakin skywalker flashbacks to stuff
during order 66 and before he was burnt before he
lost the high ground post all the memes so with
hayden christensen coming back to do all this
anakin skywalker darth vader stuff a lot of you
have also been asking if that means they'd also
try to do some sort of live-action ahsoka tano
anakin skywalker scenes either using flashbacks
or in present day with an older version of ahsoka
using force ghost anakin so that you could have a
scene with the two of them speaking to each other
in live action at this point anything is possible
given what dave filoni has been doing the past
couple of years he's been trying to do as many of
these animated characters in live action and have
it all make sense in the timeline and think about
what he did with the final clone wars episodes
the whole point of the final clone war season
7 episodes the reason they overlap with revenge
of the sith is because he wanted to work ahsoka
and wrex the other major clone wars characters
from animation into the official movie canon
so like why wasn't ahsoka there helping anakin
one of her greatest regrets and i hope that
they cover this during the ahsoka series
is that she feels like if she had been there
with anakin during the events of revenge of
the sith she could have stopped him from
turning to the dark side and saved him
you get a sense for some of that when she's
talking to mando about grogu's history in order
66 about how the jedi order is almost all gone
now but he just brought ahsoka tano into live
action with bo katan and grand admiral thrawn
these other animated characters so it makes
sense that he would also want to work them into
the movie canon as well do that in live action
you guys can let me know in the comments though
would you rather see force ghost anakin talking
to older ahsoka or would you rather see flashbacks
with the two of them because rosario dawson still
looks almost as young as she did 15 to 20 years
ago so it actually wouldn't be that hard to just
make her look like a younger version of ahsoka
but according to the star wars people and given
all these easter eggs the big event crossover that
the ahsoka series ranges the new republic and the
mandalorian are supposed to culminate in as they
were talking about at the disney investor meeting
will be them defeating grand admiral thrawn and
maybe moff gideon and when they said that the
series will all culminate in a big crossover
event they did not say when that would happen
i think that just depends on how long these other
spin-off series run they've already confirmed that
they're getting ready to ramp up to production
on the mandalorian season 3 that'll be releasing
episodes starting christmas day 2021 next year
they've already announced their release date
which is pretty crazy the ahsoka series in the new
republic series probably won't premiere till 2022
so what's probably going to happen is next year
on the mandalorian season 3 we'll see ahsoka tano
bogatan come back maybe even grand admiral thrawn
and we'll just pick up with them right before the
events of their spin-off series begin in going
forward you'll see all the characters from all
these different interconnected series just bounce
back and forth in cameo on each other's episodes
rosario dawson didn't confirm whether or not
she's coming back to cameo in the mandalorian
season 2 finale she made it sound like she was
but that's not confirmed my video for that will
post this friday just like normal so make sure
you have alerts turned on for my channel so you
don't miss that there's so many story lines that
they have to wrap up i'm not expecting everybody
to come back for the finale but everybody you've
seen who survives the finale will wind up coming
back at some point during season three could
you even imagine everyone threatening to cancel
their disney plus subscriptions if they tried to
kill grogu in the finale or hurt him in any way
if anyone's wearing plot armor in the finale it'll
be grogu besgar forged plot armor but this is the
full spread of all those new star wars series
that they announced that are coming in the next
couple of years i will be doing episode videos
for all this stuff so it's going to be crazy
in the best possible way everyone click here
for my breakdown of that new star wars obi-wan
kenobi teaser trailer footage from this past
week and click here for my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 7 video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!